مدينه نورداغ بولايه غازي عنتاب التركيه
حي بالكامل سوي بالارض
الذين كانوا مسافرين او سياحا باسماء
معلومه في فندق نورداغ صاروا مجهولين حتى
الان على الاقل
يرقدون تحت الانقط
لقد ضمير سجل اسمائهم معهم
قصدوا هذا الفندق عابرين للنوم مؤقتا
فشاء القدر ان يناموا طويلا
هل هناك احد الجميع يترقبون صوتا او انينا
نبدا
في حاله ماساويه هنا انقاض كثيره وفي كل
مكان في نورتاغ يوجد دمار وان شاء الله
يخرج الضحايا ونلتقي مع من نحب في اقرب
وقت
لا ينقطع الرجاء في انقاذ او انتشار مزيد
من الضحايا
على ناجينا من تحت الركم يستمر عمال
الانقاذ بالبحث لكن اين وكيف يقضي من كتب
لهم النجاه ليلتهم
جاء من ولايه اسطنبول وهذا ما يقدر عليه
التحدث مع المتضررين من الزلزال ومواساتهم
وحتى تقديم الحساء لهم يريحوا وجداننا
كثيرا كنا نتمنى ان نقدم لهم اكثر لكن هذا
ما نقدر عليه لا شيء سوى خيمه ونار تكسر
البروده
وتمنيه النفس بان يكون اقربائهم بخير
اخرون تحت الانقاض انهارت بيوتنا ولا
نستطيع الدخول الى المباني
الزلزال دمر كل شيء وارتسم التفاصيل
الكارثه موجعه في الوجدان عمر الحوراني
الجزيره مدينه نورداغ جنوبيه تركيا